[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Troy Aikman the accomplished broadcaster
the notes saying and co-founder of eight
Elite lager we had that at the Super
Bowl and I think I was one of the first
to point out I said there's an eight
there with the logo you have to look at
it closely there but uh the eight can
challenge to raise money for a great
cause we'll talk to Troy about that
coming up right before I walked over and
turned on my microphone Troy Paulie my
producer goes do you know Troy Aikman's
middle name I go I I don't and I said is
Troy actually his real first name so
we're going to play a game before we get
to you who thinks Troy is Troy's real
first name
oh everybody on that side all right I'm
gonna say no it's not
what about his middle name Todd Troy
Benjamin Aikman Benjamin all right Seton
I'm going to say Troy Anthony Troy
Anthony all right Marvin I'm gonna say
Aloysius okay Paulie I'm gonna go Troy
James Aikman strong sounding uh I'll go
Thomas as his middle name all right
Paulie here we go the big unveiling well
before I give it to you Troy no offense
if you went by your middle name I don't
think you would have made the Hall of
Fame Troy sounds like a Hall of Famer
it's Troy Kenneth Aikman if you were
Kenny Aikman
Kenneth Aikman
I'm not I'm not afraid of you I'm not
afraid of the Cowboys well you should be
because my dad's my my dad's a Kenny
Aikman and he starts here in a lot of
people so
but but Kenneth that doesn't scare me as
much yeah it sounds a little soft I mean
uh Troy Troy's a more masculine name for
of course it is yes yeah it's a
quarterback's name all right
um tell me what's wrong with the
Buccaneers from a quarterbacking
perspective as you watch the game last
night
oh I there's a lot I mean there's just a
lot going on Dan with them uh I you know
I think they definitely miss Gronkowski
I think you start losing some players
that that were a part of it and then the
offensive line of course has had had
some guys that have left some injuries
that have affected them uh the inability
to run the football
um there's just there's a lot to it and
there's a lot going on with Tom as well
uh as we know and then with the staff
it's just you got to pull it together
every year and it's not easy to do and I
think a lot of times we take a lot of it
for granted when you see the
quarterbacks like we see in Green Bay
with Aaron of course and then Tom in
Tampa but uh it doesn't always come
together the way that you like and
there's been so much to overcome this
year and it's just been a struggle which
team would be easier to fix offensively
for you the Broncos the Packers the
Buccaneers
uh I think the Packers uh probably would
would be my guess I mean just just
looking at it I think uh you know I've
seen Denver now uh a couple times and
and they they've gone through their
growing pains for sure but I I would say
right now from what I see I would say
Green Bay but but even them I'm not
certain you know they've got their hands
full of course this week and I you know
I'm not certain that that when it's all
said and done that any of them are are
going to be where we expected them to be
when do do you know that it's over for
you
like when you start to go I'm I'm not
making the throws I I'm like I'm I'm
just not who I was
uh uh I I think it varies for instance
with Tom I mean I Dan I I was 34 when I
retired so I mean I I knew 11 years
before Tom Brady did I mean let's just
but I you know for me I think what
happened and I and it's probably true of
a lot of guys you know my my legs
started to go is what I felt and of
course a lot of people think I retired
because of head injury that's not that's
not true but I I do Marvel that a lot of
people say yeah he really he still has
the arm strength and I and I think that
you know Breeze was a bit of the
exception but he had some arm issues but
for the most part like I bet Brett Favre
could go out right now and have the arm
strength to do all the things that's
required to go play the game and and so
I think that's usually the last thing to
go but you you know whether it's
physical or even mental I think getting
up to play at that level the great ones
uh the Tom Brady's and the Drew Brees is
and Aaron Rodgers and those guys eyes
and even the guys of my generation Elway
Mourinho Kelly all them uh you know
mentally I think that's what gets lost
in being a great quarterback is yeah you
got to be able to get out there and play
physically but it's being able to rise
to the level mentally that allows you to
play at the level that these guys are
able to play at each week how tough is
it to go out and play a game when
something in your personal life is
affecting you
man I can't speak to that because I I
really well I guess I can uh my mom was
going through breast cancer back in 97
and and was uh I was dealing with a lot
with regards to that so uh it takes a
toll now when it goes beyond extended
family now you're talking about right in
your own home
um I I can't imagine because I didn't
even get married until going into my
last season of playing uh so that was
that was that was a honeymoon as far as
my personal life goes but uh I I can
only imagine uh the challenge and and
when you combine that when you combine
when you're having the things you're
trying to deal with in your personal
life and you don't really have the time
to spend on it because you're an NFL
quarterback uh and you combine that with
the struggles that they've had on the
field I I would imagine this has been
the hardest year in Tom's life but did
you delay marriage
strategically consciously
uh no no no I didn't but I will tell you
that in hindsight uh it was it was good
because I didn't have kids until after
I'd retired so I wasn't getting pulled
with Family Life uh and I didn't have to
try to strike a balance with all that I
was it but but it was not a conscious
decision on my part and how old are your
daughters now uh 20 and 21.
when did they know that Dad was famous
uh that's a good question
um
I you know kids don't really understand
I think when the first time someone came
up and wanted an autograph or a picture
probably when they were four they
couldn't quite figure out you know what
why this stranger was stopping us and
and doing that I think that's when they
began to think you know hey but it
probably wasn't until they were
seven before they really realized what
my background was do kids come over and
want to toss football
uh no they don't come to the house you
know but speaking of it's funny Dan that
how here we are at Halloween and I
remember when I was playing and I of
course was single and I got home from
practice and I had totally forgotten
about Halloween I mean I totally forgot
about it and kids are coming to the door
and I didn't have any candy and I didn't
know what to do and so I had a bunch of
football cards so I started signing
football cards and handing them out to
the kids as they came to the door and
the next year and I didn't know if these
kids were going to be happy or not you
know so you know kids want candy but the
next year I got candy I was ahead of it
I was smart and the kids then now I got
twice as many kids and they were totally
upset that they weren't getting football
cards that year
what was the best costume you ever went
with on Halloween
uh
I went as a vampire one year my I talked
about my father Ken Aikman that we were
discussing her earlier and he worked on
the pipeline and I put some grease in my
hair for to be to be a vampire and
grease it back and it took me a week I
finally had to use his industrial
strength in order to get this grease out
I don't know what grease I used but it
wasn't made for hair I'll say that
probably some lube you Lube up ball
bearings or something I don't know
um what did you see from the Bears that
might lead you to believe that they can
challenge the Cowboys coming up this
weekend
I I will tell you Dan that last week's
game you always go in I don't have
predictions going into games but you go
into a game broadcast and you have
thoughts on how you think it'll play out
I I've never been more wrong I I really
did not think the Bears had a chance in
that game going in against New England
on the road in The Prime Time game and
you got Bill Belichick with a chance to
take sole possession of second place on
the win list and all that but they look
good they look like a team that had 11
days to prepare and I thought Justin
fields looked improved from what I had
seen
um I I do like I like Matt eberfloose a
lot I mean I think that this team is
going to be coached and they're going to
be prepared they don't they don't have
the penalties which you would expect
they're going to continue to get better
um if they can do what they did last
week and that is Justin fields of course
was a big part of that in the Run game
not turned the ball over uh I think
defensively they'll I think defensively
they could do some things against Dallas
to present some problems but this Dallas
defense is is really really good so
they're going to be a challenge for for
Justin fields and the entire group but
you were saying this on the broadcast
these young quarterbacks always think
they can make a play especially if you
have athleticism you're always thinking
how do I extend this and I remember
Steve Young saying to me I had to shut
down that part of my brain that said
just take off and run go through your
progressions but easier said than done
when you're sitting there in the pocket
you've got guys who weigh 300 pounds
coming in to take your head off
yeah and and and they've had some issues
up front with the offensive line there's
no doubt but if you're a quarterback
that has that ability what happens is is
at a very early age of your career you
realize that hey if it's not there if
that first Read's not there I'm able to
go run and make some positive yards and
and usually a lot of you the younger you
are the more yards you're making and
then as you get older the talent of
course gets a little bit tougher around
you Steve was one of those guys who ran
like you mentioned but then he got to be
where he was a really great pocket
passer and ultimately everyone wants the
the guy who can create plays with their
legs when things break down but more
times than not you've got to be able to
sit in the pocket and deliver the
football and the more you get through
your progression so I think what happens
is
for a Young quarterback even for me for
instance and I wasn't necessarily a
runner but I could run when I was young
I ran a lot as in my first and second
year some of that was because we didn't
have a really good offensive line it was
coming together but but a lot of that
more of that was because I I wasn't
seeing things the way that I should
didn't know the offense as well as I
should didn't get through my
progressions the way that I should and
then as you start to get better as a
quarterback the ball starts coming out
quicker and you're not relying then on
your legs as much and hopefully
for a guy like Justin Fields you you
only then are running when you really
absolutely have to
who would be better in today's NFL you
or Michael Irvin
oh I would be heading shoulders better I
mean and and and Dan I'd get to throw
the ball from crying out loud I mean I
think I mean I think we you know I think
we would how frustrating was that though
that you're winning
but you're leading with Emmett
but we're what you're winning but you
know that Emmett's going to get the ball
25 times and I I didn't mind that I Dan
I can honestly say I I never never had
an issue with it but so in today's game
if if I threw the ball
and we on that drive let's say we had 10
plays and we threw the ball nine times
and we went down to the one yard line
throwing the ball nine consecutive times
and then on the tenth Play We turned and
we hand it to Emmett Smith for a
touchdown
we leave the game and if that happened
on every series this is a this is an
exaggeration but if that happened on
every series then we'd come out of the
game and people would say man Troy
didn't play very well he didn't throw a
touchdown pass and so for me
I don't look at touchdown passes I don't
look at touchdown runs I mean if a
team's scoring points then the
quarterback's doing his job it doesn't
matter to me if he's if he's the guy
throwing the touchdowns but we're in a
fantasy world yeah and we were to a
lesser extent back when I played but I
think we put way too much stock in
numbers and and that just never excited
me I mean the only numbers that mattered
to me was winning and uh and I was proud
of what we were able to do but you never
looked at what Mourinho was doing it's
like well if they gave me that
opportunity I could do that well I I
admired what Dan did I mean he was a
great player and I admired what Young
did and farv and those guys played in
offenses that in Jim Kelly those guys
played in offenses that was that was
very unique and and when when I was
playing
that you couldn't throw you couldn't
throw 30 touchdowns unless you were
throwing the ball inside the 10-yard
line which which we typically did not do
so I was never going to put up a lot of
touchdown passes but when I looked
around the league of the teams that were
throwing the ball more yeah I guess
there was a part of me that thought man
that would be kind of fun to be playing
in those systems but I I will say this
um and it's not a it's not a line I I
had the most fun because winning Super
Bowls you can't even begin to imagine
how good that feels so that was all that
mattered to me and uh and and and I was
able to do it a few times did you throw
up on Super Bowl Sunday no
no I was actually more calm I always had
butterflies and was nervous but I had a
little anxiousness going into games but
surprisingly I was at my calmest uh
before each one of those super bowl
games I'm not sure exactly why either uh
tell me what you're doing with uh eight
Elite lager
yeah we're doing an eight can challenge
and it's a chance for people to build a
pyramid of eight beer and knock them
down get creative in your videos and
we're raising some money we're going to
donate eight dollars for every uh video
that is submitted whether it's on
Instagram eight can challenge or Tick
Tock and uh we're given uh the money to
an organization called back on my feet
which helps empower the homeless
Community uh in getting them you know uh
back on their feet and uh being
productive so it's uh it's a two-fold
thing it's a chance for us to expose
eight beer to a lot of people who maybe
haven't heard of the beer or tried it
and then at the same time raise some
money for a community that desperately
needs it set a new record for the
fastest independent beer launch in Texas
history yeah yeah it's been fantastic
you talked about it when we came on the
show uh last year during the Super Bowl
week and uh it's exclusive to Texas but
it's been amazing the response has been
phenomenal and we're pretty fired up
what's the coolest thing in your office
or is that your office there yeah this
is my office the coolest thing I have
besides the pictures of my girls is this
one-eyed minion and uh and that that
people ask me about that all the time
because I when I text people the
one-eyed minion comes up but you know
when my girls were young uh we saw all
the movies and my favorite was the
minions and it became kind of a thing
with me and my girl so the one I and I
and it's got to be the one-eyed minion
uh that's the one I'm partial to so it's
it's symbolic of of my relationship with
my daughters there's no Super Bowl rings
around no no no I uh I've gotta I've got
the trophies up but outside of that I'm
not sure if anyone walked in here they
would not I think they would think I was
an engineer or something I I don't think
they'd think that I ever played football
wait there's no frame jerseys no
nothing I had a framed UCLA Jersey down
in my gym but that that has since been
replaced but
no it's just never been one of the you
know those those years Dan were
fantastic and I'm proud of them and you
know we just got done talking about some
of it uh but
you know as proud as I am of it I'm I
you know I don't want to keep looking
back and reflecting back on a time in my
life that was 25 years ago it's just uh
it's just I I'd rather look forward
um and and I I still believe my best
years are ahead of me great to talk to
you as always and uh perhaps we'll cross
paths at the Super Bowl thanks again
Troy be awesome thanks Dan that's T-Roy
Aikman is Michael Irvin that's Troy
Kenneth Aikman